[SPEAKER_05]: Early morning on the third of Well Sun as gouge.
[SPEAKER_05]: So the party had just defeated a couple of Toli agents in the inner sanctum and are sitting there wondering what to do.
[SPEAKER_05]: Lord Fairwind, who was
[SPEAKER_05]: Either captured or acting captured has said some things, but it is not entirely clear what the next acts are.
[SPEAKER_05]: So the party is going to be discussing this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you ask Lord Freyrwen if he's involved in this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I can try.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm right here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Gentlemen, I am not involved in this.
[SPEAKER_05]: Whatever this is.
[SPEAKER_05]: Shut up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, what do you mean, whatever this is?
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the seizure of the helm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Involved.
[SPEAKER_03]: Dude, I've got it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I go over to Gouge, I'll just turn my back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if you've still got Charm on, so this is just to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I still have Charm?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, Charm is work.
[SPEAKER_03]: Charm lasts for, I think, an hour or at least 10 minutes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Here, I'll double check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Gouge?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll look it up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can I talk to Fairwind one-on-one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to ask these guys if you can talk to Fairwind one-on-one?
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean...
[SPEAKER_03]: So here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_03]: If there are private conversations, we should go have them each individually.
[SPEAKER_03]: With that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just asking.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't mind standing here because I don't mind if the group hears, but I wanted to talk to Gouge and we can do it on the record if you wanted.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do want to do it on the record.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, well, I know you do, but I mean...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't care if the other, I just need to say this aside so that Fairwin and the Toli got done here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we're gonna step aside if the group can hear this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just so long as Fairwin and the Toli got done.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so basically you say, let's go over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll be right back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, Gouge, if we do decide to try to rush down, remember how he said that he had, his troops were, that they had been, they were imprisoned?
[SPEAKER_01]: The garrison, there's about 100, 150 of his men minus whoever was killed that were imprisoned.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that he might try to call out to them, we need to get him the fuck off this rock without his troops knowing, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I'm thinking, like, maybe you guys take the
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll rally the troops, get them unlocked, say we haven't even seen the Baron we were looking for, I mean Lord Farrowind, and we'll try to coordinate with the troops on the outside to retake the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: You take the Toli fuck and you take Lord Farrowind back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'd rather have the interrogation go to Jameis.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I was thinking.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the decisions.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless you were told to...
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'm just investigating.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then it seems to me that they can get information.
[SPEAKER_00]: We wouldn't be having this conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so what I'm thinking is that as we go down, we're going to need to hood him and gag him so he can't call out to his troops.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the problem is he's supposed to show us how to get to the lower level, the secret level.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what's down there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you know who's in support of the Tolis down there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we don't want this guy talking.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would...
[SPEAKER_01]: I would bet that this place is garrisoned with those hobgoblin troops that are wearing and that the Tolis are probably trying to make a deal with Lord Fairwin and maybe he's agreed to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know what Paul said or heard exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're gonna trust Paul, you're gonna take Lord Farrow, and I just wanna secret him off this island if we can take the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we can take the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if he calls out to his troops and they know that he's alive, it's gonna be harder because he's gonna be like, hey, help me, don't let them take me.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're riding this balance where he has to guide us, but if the
[SPEAKER_01]: We need a guy to tell him to remain silent.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if that works with charm, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you think about having Ty go down ahead dressed in the rust plate and everything?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to go into... Well, I mean, he can go ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: We just don't know where the secret passage is.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's got to be a secret passage because this whole from the sea side, that's all secret.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's got to be some secret door.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we can't send him too far ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there might not be a secret door coming from the inside going out.
[SPEAKER_00]: It might be just this guy out coming in.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Remember that one guy that was in the other garrison?
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that it was death to just even know about the secret.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I've got to imagine it's not a door that anybody on the inside of this keep would ever stumble into.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm just saying there's going to be this thing where we've got to have them guide us, but we also need to be ready to like, you know,
[SPEAKER_01]: Not kill him, but subdue him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if you're better at that.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me, I usually just try to kill people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Same.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, somebody needs to be ready to do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, do you want to ask questions?
[SPEAKER_03]: These two kind of walk away.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to ask questions while they're gone?
[SPEAKER_06]: The only thing I would ask Fairwin is just, like, do you have any idea, like, between me and you, do you have any idea how the hobgoblins at all got here or any information on how many there are or what we're going against?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, me, you, and Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: The hobgoblins got here on a ship that the Toli brought.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's known as the Sea Ghost.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's owned by Kane Toli.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you know, perchance, if there's anything more of a threat that we're gonna go against?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, you'll have as much threat as you wish.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or not.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, if you'd like, you could free me right now and you'll have no threat.
[SPEAKER_03]: So...
[SPEAKER_05]: Paul, I respect your uncle quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: And even though he deems himself to be the first among equals, he is not the ruler in this land.
[SPEAKER_05]: Doesn't really matter.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because you are a traitor and you have been accused of treason and I will bring you to the courts of the principalities.
[SPEAKER_05]: The courts of the principalities?
[SPEAKER_05]: I've never heard of those.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're all powerful.
[SPEAKER_03]: You get what I'm trying to get at.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I want to know what you're trying to get at.
[SPEAKER_05]: Am I not a lord in this land that has as much power as... No, right now you're under accused of treason.
[SPEAKER_03]: Treason to who?
[SPEAKER_05]: What treason do you think I have done?
[SPEAKER_05]: You're a traitor.
[SPEAKER_05]: To who?
[SPEAKER_05]: To us.
[SPEAKER_05]: To you, Paul Rivera.
[SPEAKER_05]: What allegiance do I owe you?
[SPEAKER_06]: You're lucky I don't understand this as much as I do.
[SPEAKER_06]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I mean, nobody's interested in usurping your authority other than you need to talk to Prince Gion.
[SPEAKER_05]: I will talk to Prince Gion, but not under duress in this way.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, yes, you will.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, I will, but not as a prisoner.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, you will as a prisoner.
[SPEAKER_05]: We can decide that later.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right now, what we need to know is how many people are down...
[SPEAKER_04]: Below, we need to actually find out how many we have downstairs that we're gonna have to fight in order to get this back.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what we need to know now.
[SPEAKER_02]: How many of your garrison were slain when the hobgoblins came?
[SPEAKER_05]: None.
[SPEAKER_05]: You had them surrender?
[SPEAKER_05]: I did not have them surrender.
[SPEAKER_05]: I had them moved to places where they would not be hurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: The cells?
[SPEAKER_05]: Not the cells.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not in jails.
[SPEAKER_05]: Gentlemen, I think you misunderstand what is going on here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Clarify.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know something that we don't?
[SPEAKER_05]: There is a conflict between the princes of the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is a discussion between several princes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Unfortunately, Gian did not tell his nephew exactly what was going on, or maybe he did.
[SPEAKER_05]: And Paul Rivera was remiss in actually informing you of what's really happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it sounds like, with the Toli being one of the princes, that what Paul is upset about is that you sided with the Toli?
[SPEAKER_05]: I've sided with the Toli for hundreds of years.
[SPEAKER_05]: We have an alliance with Port Toli, as do all the Outer Isles.
[SPEAKER_05]: They're equal to Prince Gian in the decision-making in the nation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is the Toli suffering like Monmurg suffering under the embargo?
[SPEAKER_05]: No one's suffering like Monmurg suffering under the embargo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, so it seems that you've sided with the Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: That would suggest that...
[SPEAKER_05]: If I side with Atoli against Monmurg, it's my business and my right to do so.
[SPEAKER_05]: Not anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not in this company.
[SPEAKER_05]: You're right.
[SPEAKER_05]: We do have Lord Jameis' Axeman standing right here before us.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we also have one of his spies as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do the rest of you understand who these two are?
[SPEAKER_03]: Have you known them before today?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or this week?
[SPEAKER_03]: As it were.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're not here to answer your questions towards us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's just move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you have him guide us to the secret passage?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I guide you where?
[SPEAKER_03]: To the secret passage below.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, you wish to go down to the... We would like to recapture the barrels that are being secreted off this island.
[SPEAKER_02]: We've seen them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wouldn't that be the best way to hold the island against the swahagin at least?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think it's the only way that Monmurg would actually survive.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have any idea of when the boat will be leaving with them?
[SPEAKER_05]: The boat has come and gone several times.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I think what's more important to understand is that for months, I have been transporting as much of the substance as possible to Fairwind Island.
[SPEAKER_05]: And it's in a location that only I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's a great reason for you to talk to Lord Jeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And this is above our pay grade, but we're still taking you to Lord Jeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't see how that's possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're gonna show us the passageway.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to try to take the ship, and...
[SPEAKER_02]: Which ship?
[SPEAKER_02]: The ship that's out there in the harbor right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: You're going to take the ship that Kane Toli is on?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: With his selected men, with this ragtag group of Marines?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hundreds of hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_05]: His personal guard.
[SPEAKER_02]: How big is the ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought it was a small ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: I printed a small ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is a small ship that goes between that ship and the big ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: The ship out in the place where they're loading.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right now we are going to be putting, trying to get that back in the water so that the sahuagin...
[SPEAKER_04]: So we can repel the sahagin.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're not gonna take Kane's ship, but we'll take the smaller ship and take you in secret to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or we can have another deal be made.
[SPEAKER_06]: How about let's maybe make deals after we...
[SPEAKER_01]: You already admitted to taking the barrels off of this island for your own benefit, knowing so that Monmurg needs the helm, so that already pits you against Lord Gion, correct?
[SPEAKER_03]: Right to remain silent.
[SPEAKER_01]: You crippled Gion by taking the barrels off of the helm, which allows the Swahada, at the very least, you have 200 dead marines in the bay straight from Monmurg to answer for.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, Prince Rivero, I do respect your father quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's an honest man.
[SPEAKER_05]: However, I think he's not aware of what is actually- My father?
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, your uncle.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I think he's not aware of what is actually occurring in the principalities.
[SPEAKER_05]: And my disagreements with him are because of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, that will be figured out in Monmurg at his office.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think you are going to get off this island alive unless I let it happen.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why is that?
[SPEAKER_03]: How will you do it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Unless you let us?
[SPEAKER_05]: I will not prevent you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I will merely let the Sahuagin take care of you.
[SPEAKER_03]: You just said that you won't get off unless you let us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unless the stores have been completely looted.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you need for me to guide you to the remaining source of the substance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then obviously I do have an advantage here.
[SPEAKER_05]: I do have a bargaining chip.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, can you do something about this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you get a little tune going?
[SPEAKER_05]: By the way, the only reason he's talking is because this guy charmed him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get it, but obviously not enough.
[SPEAKER_03]: Adrian, I think it'll play when it's off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I know, I'm just...
[SPEAKER_03]: Crazy.
[SPEAKER_04]: The deal is that while you and the rest of the princes worry about your bullshit petty things, the people of Monmurg are suffering.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nothing is going to happen until we can get the sahagin repelled, order restored, and the blockade done.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's the people of Monmurg that are suffering because all you princes are worried about your bullshit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So let's go downstairs, let's kick some ass and get some of that stuff in the water now.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're losing troops as we speak right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think he makes a very good point.
[SPEAKER_05]: It is the people of Monmurg that will suffer in this conflict.
[SPEAKER_02]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is just a prelude to Giong has abdicated.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we go?
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was gonna say, this is just making me mad listening to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that and there's more barrels being taken out as we talk.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have any idea where, like, a good stash of the barrels is on this island?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, I know where the only remaining barrels are on this island.
[SPEAKER_05]: So what's your bargaining chip?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your play in this to show us then?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, actually, very soon, I won't have a bargaining chip.
[SPEAKER_03]: As we're talking, the Tolis will be taking the rest of the barrels off the island.
[SPEAKER_05]: However, I do have a bargaining chip because I have many of these barrels as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: The ones that you secreted away.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's for the future.
[SPEAKER_05]: What I would actually like to see is that...
[SPEAKER_05]: You're able to escape yourselves from hell by land.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can escape with you on the small river of two ships.
[SPEAKER_02]: Monmurg is not that far away.
[SPEAKER_05]: I will not be coming with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You cannot stay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, you can't.
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll discuss it when we're done.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we make it out of this.
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll discuss it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can stay and go.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't care.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we make it out of this, that's the important thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to get our Marines and our people back off.
[SPEAKER_01]: You stick him on the mast.
[SPEAKER_01]: You show him if the ghost is coming to take your ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you move quickly in whatever sloop that you've got.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you secret away.
[SPEAKER_01]: What time of day is it to the DMs?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's in the morning.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like early, early morning, like maybe 3 a.m. or something.
[SPEAKER_03]: Got you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can still secret around maybe the lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if our troops, did our troops take that other lighthouse?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: They cause a diversion.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean like just the lighthouse that you had, but we didn't take that second lighthouse before.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you wish me to take you to the remaining barrels?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Use hands up.
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll worry about what's going to happen to you afterwards.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if we don't make it alive, you're on your own anyway.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll have my arm wrapped around you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Come here, buddy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so how do you guys want to walk?
[SPEAKER_03]: What's the marching order?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are there any hobgoblins down here that we're going to encounter?
[SPEAKER_03]: It glides.
[SPEAKER_03]: There are hobgoblins that are definitely stationed upon the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, it's much faster than that.
[SPEAKER_05]: But on the passage what we're going to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, there are no hobgoblins along the passage that we're taking.
[SPEAKER_05]: However, what I will say is this.
[SPEAKER_05]: There are also hoggins in the water caves.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which, if we have the barrels, we can salt the sea, which should either kill them or drive them out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's how we'll survive.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do we need to go through the caves to get to these barrels?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, the truth is that all of the barrels are being taken out of the water caves, so you will have to get to where the sahuagin are to find the barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, I have no doubt that you will be able to treat with Lord Gion as an equal, but you have to treat with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't treat with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you pointed out, we have an axe man and an agent.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you treat with Lord Gion, and I'm sure he'll treat back with you, especially for those barrels that you have.
[SPEAKER_01]: But in order to get you off and not killed by the sahuagin, we need to at least have enough barrels to secure the helm and to get you to the smaller ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have to take a shot.
[SPEAKER_03]: One barrel would secure the helm for several things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm gonna guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we can keep a few, even better.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we need to move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that we can secure it.
[SPEAKER_01]: In your safety, none of us, if we wanted you assassinated, we would have already done it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we are not in positions to make deals other than to kowtow to you, which we're not going to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: How long is the short rest?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just one hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let's not do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, I don't think we got time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're gonna go.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, uh... You still beat up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty beat up, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are your troops?
[SPEAKER_02]: You said they're not locked up.
[SPEAKER_02]: How bad am I?
[SPEAKER_02]: Your troops in the Citadel.
[SPEAKER_03]: My troops are on the lower level, and yes, they have no access to the upper level.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you have the key?
[SPEAKER_03]: Effectively, they are locked up.
[SPEAKER_05]: I do not have the key.
[SPEAKER_05]: There are hobgoblins that are guarding that passage.
[SPEAKER_03]: So it's just bolted?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's bolted and there are units of hobgoblins that are protecting us.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can cure wounds.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you wanted to free them, you could go through the sanctum to the other side and then go downstairs.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's the protected area.
[SPEAKER_05]: The hobgoblins actually are defending the passage that leads up to this area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it should be unguarded from here to go through the sanctum to free them?
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: There are goblins past the sanctum.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And probably a unit- Were your troops still armed?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: They were disarmed?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: They were- these troops were in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_03]: So where's the armor?
[SPEAKER_03]: He walked through it to get to the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We did?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll sit here in front.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, because you're gonna be, who's still in their hobgoblin outfits?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is everybody pretty nice?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think everybody is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, everybody's still got their hobgoblin makeup on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who's got, you've got Fairwind?
[SPEAKER_00]: I got it, yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who's got the Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: You've got the Toli?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So what are you guys going to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so let's do Margie.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's do Margie.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know who's in here.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll take a...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's an auto hit, but like I said, I want it straight to the brain.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you're on the back, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_03]: These are... That's Gouge and Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who's the purple?
[SPEAKER_03]: That is me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's your guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: And Lord Farrowin's right next to you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I like being in him.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Fairwind's right next to you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So let's use this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Get a small three-sided dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where are you, Paul?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm right behind Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you're next to—that's you, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_03]: And where is the Toli dude?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, the Toli dude?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, right in front of me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got him by the hair.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're grabbing the bag of his hair?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you said he had long hair.
[SPEAKER_03]: He does.
[SPEAKER_03]: Very nice blonde, long hair.
[SPEAKER_03]: He wrapped it all down, and I'm like...
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so basically, you guys walk to the stairway.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Fairwind says,
[SPEAKER_05]: Are you sure about this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there any other way to get off this island and release the blockade?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're not negotiating right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was just curious if there was any other way to get off the island.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, there's not at this point in time.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you wait, however...
[SPEAKER_06]: If we wait...
[SPEAKER_06]: How about you just take us to the barrels, buddy?
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, I'll take you to the barrels.
[SPEAKER_03]: Down the stairs.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: You guys begin walking down the stairs.
[SPEAKER_05]: The spiral staircase goes down.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the DM, really quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: The ship that we saw, it sounds like what he's saying is that there's a little skiff that comes out from the cave, but then there's a smaller ship, and then it sounds like after talking to Lloyd Fairwing, he's saying the ghost, Kane Toli's ship, is actually further out.
[SPEAKER_03]: The Seaghost you saw.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, we did see it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was 300 yards off the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: It wasn't huge, it wasn't giant, but it was a Trader, bigger than a Cossaire.
[SPEAKER_03]: A Wallian ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: But very fast.
[SPEAKER_03]: Made for speed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you can't, we can't get, if we can't take the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was thinking maybe there's an intermediate ship of intermediate size that we could use to get back to.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is that smaller ship going back and forth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but that's the skiff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we talking like it's like the little ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we talking this with a sail?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's bigger than that.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, it's something...
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a ship that's probably a moderate size.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's probably about 50 feet long.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And they're used a lot by smugglers who want to make it in and out of the NRI.
[SPEAKER_03]: That ship could get us back to Monarch.
[SPEAKER_01]: Easily.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're in the middle of the ocean.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys will have to, I don't know, get lucky, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe the one Toli guy you can show him if you have to, but they'll still try to board you if they see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let's just see what we got.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we can, I think we can, if we got barrels, we can negate the swahagin.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep, definitely.
[SPEAKER_03]: Problem number one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then, yeah, then we'll deal with the cane.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can have my homocula lead the way, by the way, to see what's in the next room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is Cain Toli's ship positioned so that he could see the skiff, try to hug the coastline and get away?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: In broad daylight?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's just, I have to, like, Cain Toli's ship would see the skiff.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I could see it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe not.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I can walk.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can walk and do other things.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just not easy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like if I was, if we were in a fight, I'd stop.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we got to be even sneakier because we'd probably need the nighttime if you were going to try to take that ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if that ship will still be unloaded.
[SPEAKER_01]: It depends on how many barrels there are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it sounds like they're
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got limited time to secure at least a barrel, so we've got to get down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, maybe we've got to sneak like two or three barrels away.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll probably get like, two or three.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean like, one to clear the hardboard.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long did he say?
[SPEAKER_02]: How long did he say he said one barrel to secure the home for Helen?
[SPEAKER_02]: A couple days.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do we even know how to...
[SPEAKER_01]: If it's dust or some kind of silica that gets in their gills, it's probably just dust and you have somebody throw it out in the surf.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or at least out in it, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, so you begin walking down the spiral staircase.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you descend maybe 60 feet, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: And then the staircase ends in this 20 by 20 room that has kind of a rock-hewn rock.
[SPEAKER_03]: That rough-hewn passage basically cut out of rock that starts leading towards the north.
[SPEAKER_03]: Basically towards where the ship will be if you're going to go there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's dark down here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But no secret passages that we've seen yet?
[SPEAKER_01]: No secret doors?
[SPEAKER_01]: You haven't seen any secret doors or anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to make double sure because if we have to use them again for any reason, I want to know where they are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you guys want to like torches?
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: It's dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who here does not have dark vision?
[SPEAKER_01]: Raise your hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: Humans.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bunch of white folks.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're outvoted.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I just cast... What's the safest light source?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's in front?
[SPEAKER_00]: Me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have a shield?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I cast light on the outside of your shield.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where's the lighting for down here?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's torches.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can cast light on his shield.
[SPEAKER_01]: It'll still be seen in advance, but so will torches.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can cast light on his shield, though, and that'll probably give us all enough so that we can kind of see.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can you see in the dark, though?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you want to take up front with Gouge?
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: No?
[SPEAKER_06]: Because he's got the prisoner.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was going to say, remember I'm holding the Toli guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I don't trust him because he's an agent also, so he's probably also a mage fighter.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if we encounter somebody...
[SPEAKER_00]: Dagger up to his neck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Depends on who they're loyal to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Loyal to one of these two.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're in front, remember, you'll be in shadow because I'm casting light on your shield, so we'll be broadcasting forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I don't think we would need another torch.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll bring up the rear.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rest of you guys can walk a little closer to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Human.
[SPEAKER_03]: You cast light on Tyrus' shield.
[SPEAKER_03]: On his shield, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so light basically illuminates up to 20 feet, allowing you to see brightly lit 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: 20 feet past that is dimly lit.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it lasts for one hour.
[SPEAKER_03]: I love that clinking out.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, Fairwind says, do that passage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, as you approach the front of the passage,
[SPEAKER_03]: You hear the sea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: We're close.
[SPEAKER_03]: And after about 10 feet, 15 feet, Gouge, you come to a rickety, five foot wide bridge.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's not horribly rickety, but it's pretty narrow and whatever.
[SPEAKER_03]: And basically you're coming into a cave.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's narrow, but sort of goes off into the darkness.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you hear water below you.
[SPEAKER_03]: In front of you is just darkness.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, you can see 40 feet in front of you, but it's dim out to that range, and you see this thing just continuing in the distance, turning corners, going down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Across from the bridge, the other part of the cave.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, it's not a bridge.
[SPEAKER_03]: What it is is a passage, so it looks like this.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's built into the garbage.
[SPEAKER_05]: Here's the room.
[SPEAKER_05]: Here's the little passage you guys took.
[SPEAKER_05]: Here's the stairwell that comes down.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not a very good drawing of it, but whatever.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then this opens up into a cave, and there's a chasm here.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like you're above the water, and there's a drop-off.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then there's a little...
[SPEAKER_03]: Kind of built into the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wooden thing on the side.
[SPEAKER_06]: If we find the barrels, we could ride them like in The Hobbit.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not Hobbit-sized.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, he wants to get thrown off because a prisoner pushes him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I suggest tying yourself to him and
[SPEAKER_00]: You tie yourself to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tied myself?
[SPEAKER_00]: They push you, they're going with you, so I think that's the only way you can guarantee you're not going to be freaked out off here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are we talking, is it surf?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is it over like a... No, my guy, my guy's dad.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, so this is what it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a small, basically like a little wood on the side of the cave.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, that's a sidewalk, like a sidewalk basically built into the side of the cave.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, is it down in the water?
[SPEAKER_04]: And this is all ocean and cave out here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can hear the water.
[SPEAKER_06]: No railing?
[SPEAKER_06]: Tyrus, can you call him no railing?
[SPEAKER_06]: Shine your light on the water for me really quick.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I'll get up the edge.
[SPEAKER_05]: This place is a dump.
[SPEAKER_05]: Shine down.
[SPEAKER_06]: I want to see, uh, is there any sharks or sahuagin that I can see in the water?
[SPEAKER_06]: Like, get a relative how deep the water is?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so the water is farther than 40 feet at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can't see.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't see the bottom.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can hear it though.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not worried about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got my guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's true.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Fairwin's not going to throw himself off the bridge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hell no, man.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fairwin's a good guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got him.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll head down the pathway there with the light.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Same March murder.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think we got a single file.
[SPEAKER_06]: What's the file?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: How would that work?
[SPEAKER_06]: Prisoner in front.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll hold him like this.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know if I want to be...
[SPEAKER_03]: Put your head on your shoulder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Splitting him, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, switch from here.
[SPEAKER_00]: To his ass.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nope, not his ass.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right below so he knows I'm gonna like take his junk off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, Gouge is like, Dirty Elf.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: You doing alright, Keaton?
[SPEAKER_03]: The water?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I'm good.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm running.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can't swim.
[SPEAKER_06]: He can't swim.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can't swim.
[SPEAKER_06]: But he's a sailor.
[SPEAKER_06]: In real life.
[SPEAKER_06]: In real life, I can't swim.
[SPEAKER_06]: So he's getting a little nervous.
[SPEAKER_06]: You see him?
[SPEAKER_06]: He's shaking.
[SPEAKER_06]: That should be your character trait.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can't swim.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know if you can work against his armor.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's the flaw.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're a marine, but you can't swim.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see, where are we at?
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom, wait for us to get a little bit ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to make sure this is okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Stay at the edge and we're going to head out for a little bit and I'll turn the signal you up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there a cavern above us?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shine that shield up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see the top.
[SPEAKER_03]: You see something moving.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's no, uh, Karmurg or, um, Vladdang.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're in the mouth of a beast.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_06]: If we're getting approaching the past 20 feet before this
[SPEAKER_00]: Bridge-like thing, wooden structure ends, let me know because then we're gonna be out of light.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so how many feet are you gonna let them go ahead of you before you follow after them and tell Fairwind to go after you?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a question that might answer this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Since we see water or can hear water, is it still completely black or is there some natural light?
[SPEAKER_03]: You can't see water and you can't see light.
[SPEAKER_03]: The caves are such that there is no opening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Use your cloak if you need to cover up the light on your shield.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys go forward.
[SPEAKER_03]: You step forward.
[SPEAKER_03]: And obviously this was not meant to carry cargo.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is for personal, one person walking on this stuff.
[SPEAKER_05]: In other words, what I'm trying to say is you wouldn't be carrying treasure up to here.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is like a- Or barrels or anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or barrels or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is for one person walking.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you sure that this is the only way to go down the cave?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've never been here, so... Say just go up to those 20 feet and check it out.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've only heard about this...
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know if you're ahead of me, but...
[SPEAKER_06]: I've only heard about this cave.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've never actually been in it, I don't think.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is the only way that... Farewell's the only one here that would know.
It seems fun.
[SPEAKER_04]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so keep going.
[SPEAKER_04]: Down this rickety bridge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Quit stalling.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you basically go, let's keep going, and you keep walking forward.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to just walk?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I'm going to be as stealthy as I possibly can here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you're stealthy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know you have a light on your shield.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, but I mean, I'm not going to be like this, but I'm going to be like walking along the edge, you know.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're crouching as you go across the bridge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm prepared here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Little tiptoes.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think that's more you can do than water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, no, but I mean, I'm gonna be as careful and cautious as I possibly can.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not gonna just traipse along here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna be careful as I'm walking and keep the light against where I'm going.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, so roll a 20-side die and tell me what you get.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you work forward, the boards underneath your feet creaking as you move, and you walk 20 feet onto the platform?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, pause at 20 because I want them to be able to see us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ask him if this is the only way to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: All of them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Especially the clear one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just in case.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I'll go back to Gadget.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ask him if this is the only way to where the barrels are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ask Farrowman if this is the only way to where the barrels are.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can ask him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom, is this the only way to the barrels?
[SPEAKER_06]: Hey, bud.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is this the only way to the barrels?
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is it the safest way to the barrels?
[SPEAKER_05]: There is an entrance, as you know, through the sea.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can get there that way.
[SPEAKER_05]: And there is another way.
[SPEAKER_05]: An entrance from the beach on the other side of the home.
[SPEAKER_05]: A small cove that is not accessible unless you climb down a cliff.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to say no.
[SPEAKER_00]: How wicked do these things seem?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the heaviest by far.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, definitely they're better than the furniture and birds bar.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then does it look like it's, if we're all on it, is it just like one beam or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like if we all are on it, it's going to be a lot?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or is it like structured different areas?
[SPEAKER_03]: There are different areas.
[SPEAKER_03]: And actually, you know, I think what it is, they're slats of wood, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: And they're spaced like that much, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Now the deal is...
[SPEAKER_03]: If any one of them is rotted or bad and you put your foot on it, it could be bad.
[SPEAKER_03]: And obviously, the weightier you are, the worse it could be.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Tyrus is kind of the test monkey at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because if it holds his weight, it's gonna hold anybody else's.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I signal...
[SPEAKER_00]: Cause if it's not one span where we're all on it, making it like, oh fuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not going on until you guys go off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So signal him to keep in with 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keep within 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then once you're there, you're going to signal them.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: How far can you see in the dark?
[SPEAKER_04]: Wow, these guys look professional.
[SPEAKER_04]: They got their signals.
[SPEAKER_04]: How far can you see in the dark?
[SPEAKER_04]: 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I don't trust anybody else with this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: How far down?
[SPEAKER_02]: 68.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I hit a couple edges of the rocks on the way down?
[SPEAKER_03]: There?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you would.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys begin proceeding.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wait until they're off the bridge before I bring the Toli guy on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And who's behind me, or is it just me?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you're behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's you.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is your... Merrick is behind you, basically watching behind to make sure you're back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just checking.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's bringing up the rear.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's new?
[SPEAKER_03]: Anyway, you guys begin to walk down...
[SPEAKER_03]: I assume you guys are going, you're being cautious.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, very cautious.
[SPEAKER_03]: So Hotsby, which is 15 feet per round.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, very cautious, testing the boards as you go.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you go about, I would say, 60 feet, and there's more than one board that you're like, no, I'm not going to risk that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right?
[SPEAKER_03]: And you're happy that you're being very cautious about this.
[SPEAKER_03]: I wouldn't say that any particular one of them you say, oh, this is definitely gonna break.
[SPEAKER_03]: But you're like, I will step up to that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will try the next one in line before you continue.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if you're fine with Tyrus being this cautious, then you don't have to speed him up.
[SPEAKER_03]: You see what he's doing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're not... Yeah, and I'm okay with that because...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna go, it's gonna go with you, so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Anyway, 60 feet in, Fairwind says to you, what is your name, boy?
[SPEAKER_06]: Can we like whisper?
[SPEAKER_06]: So like, just in case things are around us?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I'm Folsom, the Marine Bard.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm assuming you're pharaohine.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm a look pharaohine, yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: You seem like a very nice young man.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why have you fallen in with these cutthroats?
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, just following orders.
[SPEAKER_05]: From?
[SPEAKER_05]: The captain.
[SPEAKER_05]: I was set on this mission.
[SPEAKER_06]: I wish that I could speak with Paul Ribeiro in private.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, we can totally do that, but maybe like when we're out of the caves?
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe on like, when everything is settled around here.
[SPEAKER_05]: You should know that Prince Gian
[SPEAKER_05]: He's being betrayed by one of his greatest advisors.
[SPEAKER_05]: Have you heard of Lord Jameis?
[SPEAKER_05]: Fairly, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, of course.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's a very famous man.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know that he's been in touch with agents from Keoland?
[SPEAKER_05]: I believe not, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know who his wife is, don't you?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm assuming I would.
[SPEAKER_06]: Lady Jameis.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know of her.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know who her brother is?
[SPEAKER_05]: Not off the top of my head, no.
[SPEAKER_05]: His name is Lord Zafar Azain.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's actually a high noble in Keoland, assigned directly to the Duke of Gratsel.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know who the Duke of Gratsel is, of course, don't you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, he's the powerful lord of Keoland.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's actually a big enemy of the city principalities.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's his navy that's blockading Monmurg right now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Lord Jameson's wife's brother is...
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's not the greatest news.
[SPEAKER_05]: You didn't know that, did you?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I did not.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not common knowledge.
[SPEAKER_05]: However, it's something I keep my eye on quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Zafar Zane has been at Lord Jameis' castle several times over the last few months.
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe Lord Jameis is a train.
[SPEAKER_05]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know who Gouge is?
[SPEAKER_05]: He points up to the guy that is leaving.
[SPEAKER_05]: I've known him for about a day or so.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's one of James' murderers.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's killed many people.
[SPEAKER_05]: Not a nice person, as it were.
[SPEAKER_05]: The elf is one of his henchmen.
[SPEAKER_05]: They've
[SPEAKER_05]: I've done many jobs for Lord Jameis in the past.
[SPEAKER_05]: It wouldn't go well for you if I was killed, as it wouldn't go well for your other compatriots.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm thinking of a large man who seems to be honest and, um, Merrick, who I know and actually appreciate.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good, honest, loyal men of the principalities, I would say.
[SPEAKER_05]: And Paul Rivero, I hope, he knows what he's doing.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think he's trying to be loyal to his father, but what I would suggest is you do your utmost to try and allow me to survive this encounter with
[SPEAKER_05]: Gouge, and Jude the Wizard.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, there's so many questions to ask upon, you know, just the information that you laid upon me now.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know you the best, and I know you don't know me.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can assure you that I will do everything I can to keep you alive so we can question you in terms of...
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not going to be questioned, and this is what I want to assure you.
[SPEAKER_05]: You will survive if I have my way.
[SPEAKER_05]: As will your compatriots.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, Gouge, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think he is an agent of Lloyd Jameis and I think Jude is as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: But understand that if you do not resist, you'll be fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_05]: And also know that if I do not survive this, please go to my family and tell them of what I spoke of with you.
[SPEAKER_05]: And also tell Paul Rivero of my concern that I think Lord James is a traitor and has been working and talking to Zafara Zane, who is known to be
[SPEAKER_05]: Again, head of the Office of Forbidden Magic in Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_05]: I know these things might not mean much to you, but understand they're a secret organization of wizards that have the destruction of the Principality as their goal.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you understand?
[SPEAKER_05]: I do understand.
[SPEAKER_05]: These are dangerous, dangerous times.
[SPEAKER_05]: And the reason I'm taking the actions I'm taking, they're for the survival of
[SPEAKER_05]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like I said, I'll do everything I can to make sure you survive this.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I know we're buds right now, but I can't assure you that you would be questioned, but I can assure that surviving...
[SPEAKER_05]: I appreciate your honesty and your support.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here, hold on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Jameis.
Right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then his wife, Lady Jameis.
Lady Jameis.
[SPEAKER_02]: Her brother, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Her brother is Zafar Azain.
[SPEAKER_03]: Rough spelling on that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Z-A-F-A-R. A zane is A-Z-A-N-E. E and then he is blocking.
[SPEAKER_03]: He is working for the Duke of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_03]: Working for the Duke of Gratzel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Who's the A?
[SPEAKER_05]: And he is head of an organization known as the Office of Forbidden Magic.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's running it?
[SPEAKER_05]: He runs the Office of Forbidden Magic.
[SPEAKER_03]: The Duke of Gratzel is like a king over in Keoland, one of the greatest nobles in Keoland, and it's actually the Duke of Gratzel whose navies are blockading Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is kind of like an ancient enemy to the Sea of Principalities.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, the Duke of Gratzel, one of its ancestors, used to be the King of Keoland, and that ancestor is the one that actually attacked the Sea of Principalities 150 years ago.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ancestor.
[SPEAKER_06]: Attacked.
[SPEAKER_06]: Don't just act in a minute.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sea of Principalities.
[SPEAKER_06]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_06]: I just want to write it down so I don't forget.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
Cool.